ah
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález continuamos
haciendo seguimiento de los temas que
han tenido lugar a lo largo de esta
semana en ucrania el mundo entero se
estremeció y vio también con terror las
imágenes de las muertes de civiles en la
ciudad de buzzi en los suburbios de kiev
la capital ucraniana
las imágenes que mostraron una de las
caras más terribles hasta el momento de
la guerra en ucrania veamos
aquí cinco cuerpos encontrados atados en
un sótano aquí una fosa común llena de
gente vestida de civil en lucha al norte
de kiev las autoridades ucranianas
presentaron a la prensa lo que denuncian
como crímenes de guerra rusas reportan
que 300 civiles han muerto aquí el
presidente ucraniano tras visitar la
zona se mostró preocupado
los ocupantes probablemente tratarán de
ocultar las huellas de sus crímenes no
lo hicieron en lucha cuando se retiraron
pero en otra zona es posible
en busca kiev no tienen ninguna duda de
que rusia irresponsable y se apoyan
especialmente en estas imágenes
suministradas por satélites
estadounidenses y muestran los cuerpos
de los civiles en la carretera desde
mediados de marzo el kremlin afirma que
los cuerpos fueron arrojados tras la
retirada del ejército ruso siguen
denunciando una puesta en escena
mientras que las fuerzas rusas
abandonaron la zona de duchas ya el 30
de marzo como parte de una
durante los tres días siguientes el
alcalde habló en televisión diciendo que
la ciudad estaba volviendo a la vida
normal las fuerzas ucranianas también
aparecieron allí se mostraron calles
donde no había cuerpos de seguridad muy
pocas las autoridades rusas dicen que
documentarán en lo que llaman la
verdadera naturaleza de los
acontecimientos en muchas moscú tiene
previsto presentar el martes ante el
consejo de seguridad de la onu pruebas
de su no implicación
rápidamente hubo reacciones a nivel
internacional y también señalamientos a
rusia y a su presidente vladimir putin
quien es calificado por ejemplo por la
casa blanca en eeuu como un criminal de
guerra buena parte también de la
comunidad internacional calificó estos
asesinatos como crímenes de guerra que
deben ser investigados por lo menos así
lo mencionó el canciller alemán olaf
scholz te amo don fotos y el asesinato
de civiles es un crimen de guerra
debemos investigar sin descanso estos
crímenes de guerra cometidos por las
fuerzas armadas rusas
y presidente putin y sus partidarios
sentirán las consecuencias y seguiremos
proporcionando a ucrania armas para
defenderse de la invasión rusas de un
técnico ya lo decíamos en el reportaje
rusia ha rechazado las imágenes y dicen
que son producto de la falsificación
y
por lo que hemos visto las imágenes de
vídeo en muchos aspectos uno no puede
confiar en ellas porque es obvio
nuestros expertos del ministerio de
defensa han identificado signos de
falsificación los hechos y la cronología
de los eventos tampoco respaldan la
autenticidad de esta ley en este vídeo
por hugo se suma a todos estos hechos
también el repliegue de las tropas rusas
que hacen temer una posible escalada más
sangrienta en el futuro próximo también
la prolongación del conflicto los pocos
avances de la diplomacia para poder
resolver este conflicto la posibilidad
de que existan crímenes de guerra
cometidos por ambos bandos y que rusia
amenace la pretensión de algunos países
como por ejemplo finlandia de entrar en
la otan lo que hace pensar que se podría
abrir otro escenario por lo menos de
conflicto y de discrepancias entre
helsinki y moscú también genera
preocupación en la escena internacional
por todo lo que esto conlleva teoría
económica y en materia de abastecimiento
a escala global hoy en el debate de
france 24 analizamos los hechos más
importantes a lo largo de esta semana
relacionados con la guerra en ucrania
pero eso sí hacemos foco en los hechos
de lucha estamos hablando de clic
crímenes de guerra pues para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a melina torus
ella es analista internacional
especialista en geopolítica es
secretaria del departamento de eurasia
del instituto de relaciones
internacionales también es coordinadora
del observatorio de seguridad y defensa
en el centro de estudios de política
internacional de la facultad de ciencias
sociales de la universidad de buenos
aires por supuesto en buenos aires la
capital argentina pero desde madrid la
capital española se conecta a esta
conversación juan avilés él es profesor
emérito de historia contemporánea de la
universidad nacional de educación a
distancia allí en el reino de españa
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas pueden
hacerlas a través de las redes sociales
no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
arroba france24 jon bajo s y sant y
luego que es mi cuenta personal
rápidamente les recuerdo nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas para que participen y sean
parte del debate comienzo entonces con
emelina en la ciudad de buenos aires-
primero le doy la bienvenida del
programa melina gracias por estar con
nosotros y comienzo preguntándole por
los hechos de la ciudad de lucha que es
un suburbio de quien la capital
ucraniana los hechos que están allí que
es lo que evidencia a qué nivel ya que
escala estamos llegando en este
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania que
primero pensábamos que iba a ser un
conflicto corto que iba a ser una
captura de kiev muy rápida y este
conflicto ya pasa más allá de los 40
días
bueno buenas noches santiago un gusto
estar con ustedes el 24 de nuevo bueno
que bien sean estas imágenes evidencian
lo más crudo lo que es la guerra lo que
todos teníamos que llegar a pasar todo
como bien decía que estábamos recordando
a quitar la guerra que fue en soria que
en 2017 2008 que en 15 días nada más y
que cumple sus objetivos y se logró un
acuerdo al cuello que si bien todavía
están las intenciones separatistas estas
regiones de en soria
y hay una relativa paz por así decirlo
en los conflictos en realidad nunca hay
una paz estable pero pensamos que quizás
podría pasar algo similar en ucrania y
también recordamos los sucesos del 2014
sin embargo vemos que esto se está
dilatando en el tiempo creo que en parte
es eso consecuencia de no poder lograr
un alto el fuego y lo que vemos son
estas imágenes que de ucrania denuncia
cuando las tropas de russian se retiran
a fines de marzo
y
pero lo que estamos viendo exactamente
son acusaciones de ambos lados como si
no puedes suceden estas cuestiones
claro que ya lo vamos a analizar más
adelante esta narrativa que tenemos cubo
en torno a los hechos en lucha y las
denuncias que hace el gobierno ucraniano
y la recepción que está teniendo esto en
la comunidad internacional saludo ahora
a juan avilés en la ciudad de madrid en
españa le doy la bienvenida el programa
y juán su opinión sobre estos hechos de
lo que está sucediendo y lo que hemos
visto a lo largo de esta semana de estas
muertes de civiles en la ciudad de lucha
y en otros suburbios de kiev tras el
paso de las tropas rusas
muy buenas noches santiago bueno esto es
un aumento del horror de la guerra pero
hay que recordar que desde el principio
las tropas rusas ha lanzado ataques
deliberados contra zonas civiles es
decir los crímenes de guerra se producen
desde el primer día pero también es un
crimen de guerra lanzar misiles contra
viviendas contra colegios contra lugares
donde que no tienen ningún valor meditar
para bien ser incluso más horrible o nos
provoca incluso más rechazo el ver como
aparentemente se ha tiroteado a personas
al azar en las calles o lo que es peor
ha habido ejecuciones extrajudiciales
como lo demuestra esos cadáveres con las
manos atadas es decir hay un incremento
del horror pero crímenes de guerra no ha
habido desde el argumento la tienda
ganase que una guerra de agresión es ya
un crimen contra el derecho
internacional
claro continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda en sentido contrario y seguimos
hablando de esta narrativa la visión que
tiene rusia que tenemos q y que las
declaraciones que dan los funcionarios
del gobierno ruso sobre estos temas
cada vez es más difícil no sé cuál sea
su impresión pero lo que uno puede notar
es que cada vez es más difícil para los
rusos mantener una misma versión y son
cambiantes las narrativas en cuanto a
los escenarios que se les va presentando
usted mencionaba los ataques a puntos
que no tienen estrategia militar eso me
recuerda al ataque a un hospital ya un
teatro en la ciudad de mariupol en el
puerto que queda ubicado en el mar de
azov que son puntos donde claramente no
hay ningún tipo de estrategia militar
hasta que ya fue completamente
insostenible para el kremlin debido a
las imágenes de la evidente destrucción
de las edificaciones y de los ataques y
las muertes y las personas que
fallecieron allí pues moscú tiene una
narrativa que no puede sostener le
cuesta mantener al kremlin estos
discursos quedan desvirtuados ante las
declaraciones que dan los funcionarios
ucranianos
si evidentemente las declaraciones rusas
carecen absolutamente de credibilidad
afortunadamente los medios de
comunicación actuales son increíblemente
superiores a los de hace muy pocos años
cosas que ocurrían pero si en yugoslavia
a fines del siglo 20 no teníamos ni una
centésima parte igual documentadas
pasaba el tiempo a pasar de los 22 días
ahora la verdad es que tenemos infinitos
medios para saber lo que pasa están los
teléfonos de móviles están las imágenes
de satélite lo sabemos muy bien lo que
ocurre es que el kremlin ya desde hace
bastantes años yo creo que si una
estrategia deliberada de lanzar
explicaciones alternativas esa
incoherencia yo creo que es casi
deliberada pasó por ejemplo hace unos
años cuando un avión civil que
transitaba sobre el donbass fue
derribado por un misil con toda
seguridad a un misil ruso también sobre
eso también dieron diferentes
o sea que tienen mucho otras versiones
diferentes yo creo que su objetivo no es
tanto convencer como aterrorizar
no convencer pero sí aterrorizar tal vez
confundir también a la opinión pública
melina su opinión en torno a este tema
de la narrativa de lo que ha dicho moscú
sobre estos hechos en muchas de estas
imágenes impresionantes que hemos
mostrado en el reportaje al inicio el
programa y los reclamos y las evidencias
que muestran ucrania
donde puede haber posibles crímenes de
guerra pero ojo aquí hay crímenes de
guerra y hay evidencias de ambas partes
tal como decían tantos como juan también
hay que recordar que estamos ante una
situación de emergencia no sólo para el
sistema internacional sino lo que
implica para la rusia y para ucrania
entonces a veces resulta difícil
continuar con una misma narrativa y
justificando tus hechos tanto a nivel
interno como a nivel externo porque a
nivel interno uno necesita generar su
apoyo porque si no si no tiene apoyo
para hacer una campaña militar de esta
de estas magnitudes puedes llegar a
pasar cosas más inimaginables todavía y
también hacia el exterior para bueno
tratar de que las funciones evitadas
canciones tan distantes como estás
haciendo ahora rusia o bien también las
sanciones que están teniendo a nivel
internacional en los organismos
internacionales
seguramente vamos a estar hablando del
consejo de derechos humanos
claro melina continuó con usted punto
importante de esta semana aparte de
estos hechos de lucha que le han dado la
vuelta al mundo es el repliegue de las
tropas rusas que estaban ya muy cerca de
la zona perimetral de kiev la capital
ucraniana y han comenzado a replegarse y
han regresado muchas de ellas a
territorios de belarús esto que nos
puede decir que es el gran temor de la
comunidad internacional que esto sea
el previo a un gran ataque a mayor
escala por parte de los rusos
y yo veo dos opciones en esto por un
lado yo creo que la presión que ejercía
sobre que la presencia militar rusa en
las afueras de quiebre estos suburbios
era más que nada para negociar
traer alguna fuerza militar está de
apoyo al término de negociación
diplomática que esto lo hacen todos los
países que tienen capacidad militar
obviamente y por otro lado
en este sentido puede ser que rusia
decida que haya decidido que el frente
de batalla se concentre solamente en el
este de las repúblicas separatistas que
ellos reconocen como independientes o
bien como muchos dicen una esfuerzo
enterraron un derramamiento y para
volver a atacar más fuerte todavía
claro juan su opinión sobre este tema
sobre este repliegue de las fuerzas
rusas puede ser el
principio de un siguiente ataque a mayor
escala o puede ser parte de la
estrategia o simplemente la estrategia
moscú no era llegar a kiev
yo creo que la estrategia más pudiera
conquistar todo trae lleva muchos años
el señor putin repitiendo que ucrania no
existe el ucrania es parte de rusia y
que hay que llegar a una ruta por cierto
en contra de un tratado firmado en 1925
el memorando un de budapest en que a
cambio de la renuncia no puede ni ver
sus armas nucleares porque en 1995 otra
[__] la tercera potencia nuclear del
mundo entrega esas armas a rusia en
buena medida por presionando occidental
y a cambio de esos hay una garantía y
firman eeuu reino unido la federación
rusa es decir que hay un acuerdo desde
hace bastantes años por el cual se
comprometieron a realidad seguir lo que
se había acordado
el respeto siempre ha sido bien útil
lleva mucho tiempo diciendo que no lo va
a respetar porque ucrania no la reconoce
una nación independiente donde
autodeterminación si es que claramente
el intento era ocupar todo planea y la
idea es que un ataque muy rápido sobre
quién podía decapitar al gamer planean
dicho el primer fracaso importantísimo
de los rusos fue cuando no lograron
asegurar un aeropuerto junto a la
capital por el cual había hubiera
demanda muchas tropas si es que su
proyecto era conquistar grandes
claramente se han encontrado con una
resistencia que no se esperaba cual dice
muy poco en favor de los servicios de
inteligencia rusos o quizá muestre que
putin no les hace caso a su propio
servicio de licencia también es posible
pero lo cierto es que hay una asistencia
que también en el fondo no se ha
planteado a todos yo creo que así todos
nos teníamos una rápida victoria después
de la resistencia se retira bueno pues
hay dos posibilidades una
y renuncien a todo plan ya lance en una
tremenda ofensiva en el donbass para
asegurarse el este y el sur de ucrania o
que vuelvan a lanzarse sobre el 10 desde
luego del profeta en estos temas no se
no es una profesión muy segura pero yo
creo que se van a concentrar en paz y en
la costa del magnet claro y siempre lo
digo yo en este programa no hay una bola
de cristal para saber qué va a suceder a
lo largo de la historia usted lo ha
mencionado y a lo largo de los últimos
años el presidente vladimir putin ha
dicho que ucrania no existe muchos
analistas haciendo la investigación para
este programa me encontré con algunos
comentarios como estas masacres de
ciudadanos ucranianos por parte de
fuerzas rusas hacen parte precisamente
de esa parte de tratar de borrar del
mapa
a los ucranianos
como parte de la de la anexión de todo
este territorio de la federación a lo
largo de la historia rusia siempre ha
tratado de pasar por encima de ucrania
usted como historiador nos puede dar un
poco más de datos sobre diferentes
escenarios en los que ucrania
prácticamente ha desaparecido bajo la
órbita del imperio ruso o de la unión
soviética o de rusia no es la primera
vez que pasa
bueno vamos a ver yo no creo en que las
naciones sean entidades
eternas
esenciales las naciones se crean y
desaparecen a lo largo de la historia
en tiempos remotos pues sería difícil
distinguir a rusia y ucrania en otra
parte ucrania no tiene fronteras
naturales claras entonces quedó muchas
veces dividida entre los polacos los
austríacos los rusos y en realidad el
nacionalismo craneal propiamente dicho
surge del siglo 19 y el
nacimiento de ucrania es con la
revolución de 1917 la revolución de 1917
toda una serie de naciones que forman
parte de ese imperio el imperio
multiétnico del imperio ruso se afirman
y buscan su autodeterminación y como
hace poco putin le ha reprochado
realmente a los bolcheviques en la unión
soviética se construye como uno y unión
de diferentes repúblicas unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas ya
nadie se acuerda pero viendo tiempos de
la unión soviética
ucrania tenía presencia en naciones
unidas como un estado diferenciado o sea
que ese es el momento en que surge es
realmente una una entidad estatal
ucraniana en cuanto a la identidad
nacional yo creo y ha ido creciendo
desde independencia claramente a pesar
la el este es básicamente de lengua rusa
o al propio felinski yo creo que esta
guerra va a ser la que soy con sangre
definitiva de una identidad nacional
ucraniana separada es decir que utilizo
para lograr lo contrario donde pues por
lo menos ha logrado despertar el
nacionalismo ucraniano y que se una para
defender a su país melina regresó con
usted después de esta explicación del
contexto histórico importante para
entender este sector del este de europa
y pasó a preguntarle por otro temor que
surgió esta semana con los hechos que
hemos visto recientemente desde el
posible alargue de la guerra
en las consecuencias que esto trae qué
costo tiene en la larga de este
conflicto para rusia para la unión
europea para la misma ucrania por
supuesto para eeuu
no una guerra de larga duración
obviamente tiene costos inimaginables y
tras arreglar un dato de color que
también para ver y magnificar la
importancia de crimea por ejemplo para
rusia está la anexa eran a finales del
siglo 18 con catalina la grande y
entonces ya de esa época se pensaban
peleando por quien manipulaba quien
controlaba esta región era controlado
para ir pero toma no pero bueno y luego
que estos conflictos se remontan a hace
mucho tiene tiempo entonces y tenemos
que irse cuál es el costo obviamente el
costo más grande que tenemos y el que no
se puede reparar son las vidas humanas
que la 1 en el día de ayer dijo que
murieron alrededor de 1.500 civiles
ese es el mayor costo que no podemos
recuperar después tenemos los puntos
económicos que por ejemplo también la
onu dijo en el día de ayer en unos días
anteriores que esta guerra lucran ya y
en entre ucrania y rusia está provocando
que en regiones como áfrica y medio
oriente la seguridad alimenticia sería
impactada dado la suba de los precios de
los alimentos no solo de los alimentos
sino también de el petróleo el gas que
son la energía y bueno necesitamos tanto
petróleo como energía para transportar
los alimentos no pueden ser que suban
aún más los precios
entonces tenemos por un lado las vías
otro efecto económico y también mi
incertidumbre a nivel internacional
claro
melina que hay de los crímenes de guerra
que posiblemente han ocurrido tanto el
lado ucraniano como el lado ruso las
acusaciones van dirigidas principalmente
por la comunidad internacional por
europa por bruselas por por washington
hacia el presidente vladimir putin y
hacia los militares rusos pueden los
militares rusos los altos rangos y el
presidente ruso responder por crímenes
de guerra dado el caso que se abra una
investigación que ya está en curso pero
que se llegue a un caso como tal que se
encuentren evidencias concretas
las cosas son siempre difíciles de
probar porque siempre va a haber dos
retóricas hay que ver cuál va a ser la
que gana porque según rusia ellos no lo
hicieron son cosas inventadas por
ucrania y bueno él la ucraniana dice no
miren esto nuestras cosas que son esto
es lo que pasó
entonces es muy difícil que respondan
ante la ley porque tampoco rusia forma
parte de la corte internacional de
justicia estamos unidos tampoco
entonces es muy difícil quizás lograr
juzgarlos
sea quien sea el que haya hecho
que cualquiera cualquier parte que no se
ha hecho es atroz si juan desde su
perspectiva la mesa de diálogo las
conversaciones y la diplomacia
están prácticamente en un punto muerto
avanzan muy lento y son pocos los
resultados
efectivos para poder terminar con este
conflicto
hay un agotamiento democrático hay un
agotamiento del diálogo entre kiev y
moscú sobre todo un agotamiento de la
diplomacia
bueno yo creo que a corto plazo hay muy
pocas posibilidades de que esas
negociaciones si ven algo y
evidentemente estos horrores que hemos
visto en lucha pues lo dificultan o más
porque es hacer van todavía más la
voluntad de no ceder pero su craneanos
por cierto en cuanto a crímenes de
guerra craneanos hasta ahora lo único
que ha aparecido es un vídeo en que me
parece que un beso dos bandas nos
rematan a un
soldado ruso
herido si es que puede haber habido un
crimen de guerra pero en fin eso es un
crimen de guerra
comparado con miles de crímenes en otro
caso digo no creo que sea fácil una pero
yo creo que ucrania no va
en el estudio ha funcionado
y yo creo que putin no va a querer
quedarse con menos de ese así es que en
el mejor de los casos piensan se podrá
llegar a un alto pues en una prueba
definitivo yo creo ya no ser que haya un
cambio de gobierno rusia no lo vamos a
ver en bastante tiempo lo deseable sería
es que uniera un alto el fuego que la
línea actual se congelará y dejara morir
lo somos pero acuerdo de paz lo veo muy
bien
melina juan también destacado a lo largo
de estos últimos días incluso en las
últimas horas el anuncio de la
suspensión de rusia del consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu los rusos
dijeron que van a seguir defendiendo sus
intereses rusia en muchas ocasiones
simplemente pasa por encima de este tipo
de anuncios y de alertas a nivel
internacional -juan esto qué
implicaciones tiene para rusia esta
suspensión y este y este anuncio hecho
por el portavoz del kremlin que dice que
simplemente seguirán defendiendo lo que
les parece a ellos que son sus intereses
bueno a efectos prácticos la suspensión
no tiene consecuencias a penas pero sí
que es importante a nivel simbólico la
realidad general es naciones unidas no
es un órgano ejecutivo no dicta
disposiciones que obliguen a todos los
países pero sí que representa de alguna
manera se ha dicho el parlamento hermano
de la humanidad y eso que una gran
mayoría de países hayan hecho esta
condena a rusia sí que tiene un valor
moral y político a mi juicio muy
importante a decir nos pasamos de la
digamos de cínicos de no dar importancia
a la moral yo creo sí la tiene
y medida su opinión
estoy de acuerdo con cuanto a lo
inmediato o sea la suspensión tiene
efectos de que no puede votar rusia pero
tampoco puede presentar resoluciones
pero si tiene un efecto simbólico y
diplomático que son 93 países que se
unieron para expulsarlo básicamente
rusia de un organismo internacional pero
también llama la atención por otro lado
la cantidad de abstenciones que hubo que
quizás puede llegar a demostrar la
influencia que tiene rusia en el sistema
internacional
claro por ejemplo la votación de mexico
que llama mucho la atención y ha sido
muy criticado en algunos escenarios
internacionales como interpretar esa
votación por parte del gobierno mexicano
a melina
bueno méxico es un caso muy especial es
dentro de américa latina está muy cerca
de lo que se conoce como el gran la gran
potencia no eeuu y también
ha buscado en estos últimos años tratar
de no depender tanto del gigante
norteamericano por así decirlo entonces
yo creo que lo que estaba buscando
méxico es tratar de nosotros un balance
que lo que también llama mucho la
atención no sólo de méxico sino de
américa latina es que no ha votado en
bloque no hay ninguna región del planeta
que haya votado en bloque no puede
llamar mucho la atención por ejemplo acá
en américa sobre bolivia voto en contra
argentina bueno sabemos que voto a favor
brasil se actúa entonces no una una
respuesta regional lo cual sea mucho la
atención si me salgo un poco de la
órbita de ucrania juan y hablo de un
país que anunció en los últimos días
también que podría unirse oficialmente a
la otan dado el escenario bélico que
está presentándose y es finlandia un
país que tiene una frontera grande con
rusia fue un territorio que incluso
perteneció al imperio ruso y desde ya ya
empezaron a hacerle advertencias al
gobierno en helsinki le dijeron que su
posible ingreso en la otan puede ser un
error estratégico y que eso obligaría a
que rusia viera a finlandia
inmediatamente como un objetivo que
alertas nos dejan no solamente para
finlandia sino para otros países que
tienen frontera con rusia y que alertas
le deja a la otan
es bueno finlandia un tiempo rosa se
independizó con la revolución del 17 y
convendría recordar que 1940 es stalin
atacó a finlandia y no consiguió
someterla después de la guerra mundial
tuvo un estatus de neutralidad en los
finlandeses como los suecos se sienten
claramente inquietos por la presencia en
sus fronteras de una gran potencia con
seis mil ojivas nucleares dispuestas a
invadir países vecinos dispuesta a decir
a sus vecinos lo que tiene que hacer en
hacer por tanto tanto en finlandia como
en suecia hay un cambio en la opinión
favorable a la incorporación a la otan
en realidad surgía venían a estar
teniendo un gasto gritar muy elevado
porque hace mucho tiempo se sentían
preocupados hasta de bastantes años
entonces es lógico que pretendan
incorporarse a la otan y probablemente
se incorporarán las amenazas rusas no
creo que me vayan a disuadir y por
cierto lo que sí fue un error terrible
cuando en 2008 se buscó una vía de medio
que ofrecidas georgia y ucrania que
podrían entrar pero al mismo tiempo no
se empezó en marcha el mecanismo de
adhesión con lo cual quedarán señalados
como posibles miembros de lauder lo cual
incrementó la paranoia de putin y la
dirección rusa por otro lado nos dio una
garantía yo creo que en este caso
probablemente vayamos hacia una lesión
rápida una visión rápida por parte de
finlandia y suecia en la otra puede ser
un escenario posible me quedan ya pocos
minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero cerrar hablando de las sanciones
las más recientes sanciones que han
puesto impuestos tanto la unión europea
como estados unidos a más entidades
financieras rusas y a dos personajes muy
particulares las dos hijas del
presidente vladimir putin las sanciones
tienen efecto vemos cada semana que
bruselas y washington impone más
sanciones pero los efectos no se ven de
manera inmediata esto cuánto va a
empezar a resultados qué es lo que está
buscando precisamente la unión europea y
eeuu sobre rusia
bueno lo de la sanción esto es un tema
que ya viene desde el 2014 vimos que eso
no había mucho efecto pero lo que llama
la atención es la dureza de ahora estas
sanciones y en el corto plazo o sea en
estos meses que estuvimos viendo no
tuvieron mucho efecto salvo más en el
intercambio comercial el tema del switch
porque rusia ya se estaba preparando
para el peor escenario estuvo aumentado
su restauración ahora también ha estado
probando en un sistema similar al swift
pero respaldado por chinas también y sus
ejercicios militares el año pasado en
donde comprobaba qué sucedería si por
ejemplo rusia esté desconectada del
internet global qué sucedería con todo
el país y bueno nada vemos que no se
estaba preparándose para un escenario
que sea el catastrófico pero hay que ver
qué va a suceder a mediano y largo plazo
que es lo que es hace un poco de
futurología que no sabemos qué va a
suceder claro y su opinión juan antes de
pasar a las conclusiones sobre este tema
de las sanciones
de las sanciones económicas sin
duda que ya se está notando que el
producto interior bruto ruso va a caer
este año lo que pasa es que eso va a
generar
una
un cambio la política rusa es está por
ver
por otro lado la sanción realmente
devastadora sería que europa dejará que
de comprar el gas ruso y eso es muy
complicado por la locura de algunos
países europeos que notoriamente
alemania que optaron por esa fuente de
suministro sin darse cuenta lo que se
estaba cociendo o sea que bien las
sanciones van a hacer daño ni a rusa
pero no sabemos cuánto los europeos
vamos por el quinto paquete de sanciones
de esta forma está probado exactamente
hoy no esto va a hacer daños va a ser
también pero sin duda alguna la fuente
de financiación del gobierno ruso es el
suministro de gas a europa y por ejemplo
alemania consume o del gas que consume
el 40 por ciento viene de rusia me queda
un minuto para las conclusiones que va a
suceder que más vamos a ver ya lo había
dicho no tenemos bola de cristal para
ver el futuro de este conflicto pero
desde su punto de vista melina que puede
suceder
yo creo que también nos toman un poco lo
que decía juan que yo estoy de acuerdo
es que lo máximo que vamos a poder
lograr va a ser un alto al fuego y va a
pasar a conformarse otro de los
conflictos congelados del espacio ex
soviético que ella tanto conocemos como
registra concedía y asia
para mí ese es el escenario más real el
estado ideal sería un alto al poder una
forma de paz
un alto el fuego y juan su conclusión
que vamos a ver más adelante a donde
podríamos llegar en este conflicto
bueno de acuerdo con el inah con lo cual
no me repito lo que sí que voy a añadir
es que rusia ha entrado en una vía de la
cual es deseable que salga pronto pero
yo no creo que voy a salir pronto ha
hecho una opción realmente terrible bien
y en cuanto a europa yo he visto lo que
va a suponer es un reforzamiento de la
integración europea y que la integración
europea vaya camino de convertirse
también en un sector militar siempre
alemán en alemania claro es una gran
novedad y rompe con muchos años lo venía
pasando en mi vida pues a juan ya melina
les agradezco mucho por este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 en
américa latina muchas gracias a ustedes
por la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo en manos de luis
fernando montes y la producción de
invitados de tania herrera el nombre del
equipo y el nombre del máster de
producción también les agradecemos la
sintonía siga con nosotros
[Música]